[Musique]
le deuil est une drôle d'épreuve
un jour on croit en être sortis et puis
non est toujours là incrustés exa colère
[Musique]
que mon frère aussi lui couper la tête
d'une certaine façon des jazzmen famille
des rescapés
tu verras mobile prononcé roberta ça
n'est que le lâcherai pas ce qu'il ya
des ennemis contre lequel on ne peut pas
lutter je parle de vous de votre ennemi
intérieur
mon café foutu voix très oublié mois
justin tu fais chier 1
c'est sûr que tu vas aller dans ce
merdier
vous êtes là pour servir la france comme
pour régler vos comptes
je la serre la france
moi je suis libre revient de ce soir ce
soir je peux pas d'un match va peut-être
là
[Musique]
je veux pas crever ici
soit on maintient que j'ai pas envie de
parler
[Musique]
je serai jamais comme je pars m'attend
l'amour rend chaque forme de place à la
place et vous le mettre à qui le placent
la france
[Musique]
bah